look at this these are real tattoos this
is a Fan's tattoo of Charlie looking
like an ass
a nice Rob tattoo yeah I think we have a
Danny yeah
how do you feel about that Danny I mean
that is yeah cool that's on Danny
that's on Denny's and then uh I think uh
Glenn yeah there's a Glenn tattoo yeah
yeah I mean that is it that is a
commitment that's going to be there for
their entire life it's it is a big deal
you want to make sure that you're
picking your favorite care I mean I
don't think it's that strange to make a
choice like that I just think that
you've got to make sure you're picking
somebody you really feel strongly about
I also I've never liked anyone that much
personally I mean I have a I have a
tattoo of somebody who I've admired for
many many years on my body who's a
television character and a film star oh
really yeah can we see it is that okay
you guys want to see it yeah what's your
tattoo it's cool
[Applause]
good night